une fois parce que moi je déteste le
coup d'un soir oui mais on est mal barré
oui sans langue de bois
oui non vous savez pourquoi pourquoi est
ce que quand je fais ce genre de choses
après je m'attache très très vite non
vraiment trop vite et je peu après est
une espèce de force euse mais vous savez
que je vous dise moi je pense que j'ai
un témoin je pense qu'on s'attache oui
on s'abandonne non mais si après il n'a
fait pas en me disant non mais c'était
juste comme ça je vais très mal vivre
géré dgo donc non je pourrais le
harceler delphine non moi non plus ça
mais jamais parce que moi aussi je
m'attache tout de suite après donc la
deûle film mais n'ont jamais moi j'ai g3
chéri dans ma vie et puis c'est ce
compte sur roy et tout le monde sait qui
c'est l'e3 c'est vrai voilà c'est vrai
c'est vrai çà et là des films qui fête
son anniversaire et cros g aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui près de 50
concerts en 25 ans qui sont rencontrés
écroulé et ben jabr à ce projet et
ouakka audio non et puis peut être
surtout parce que je suis fidèle parce
que ça fait 18 ans que tu vois avant les
18 ans avant il ya différents noms parce
que j'avais 18 ans a bel et bien avant
ça m'a jetée patiente et moi j'aime pas
été j'ai rouler des pelles je vais être
comme ça mais j'ai pas à rouler des
pelles
ouais j'ai roulé quelques pelles et
c'est tout on a roulé des patients c'est
super car quoi ah ouais bah va étonner
on non quelle mais moi je voulais dit
l'autre jour non non moi j'aime bien au
contraire c'est très pratique mais cette
année elles vous font pas chier et ce
bar le lendemain ou même même à une fois
finie elle dégage lors
ouais alors merde comme vous tuez vous
parlez très mal alors quoi de sérieux
pour être sérieux
évidemment je préfère laventure nomme ça
ce n'est pas de dire ça c'est pas alors
évidemment je préfère les aventures d'un
soir c'est extrêmement agréable comme ça
il n'y a pas de compromis et pas
d'histoire et puis si on on la revoit si
on a envie si on n'a pas envie on ne
revoit pas non je suis très aventure
d'un soir moi vous avez dit la même
chose chez vous
1 mais lui il faut rigoler les juifs les
arrivées à chauffer le sarouel